merry Christmas everyone
[Music]
all right Merry Christmas everybody
great to be here with an amazing year a
lot of milestones pass got the book out
got the 500,000 subscribers super
excited for the year ahead into 2017 and
this is gonna be a quick video because
we are in the car as you can tell me mr.
side maintains in the back oh there he
is what's up Haven wow that's good we're
rets christmas havens Hayden's light and
wear red we're doing a quick pit stop
tonight we're wait until it gets dark
which it is now and we're gonna go check
out this amazing home that has over
50,000 light bulbs turned on the
decorate the house is family called the
deSario family every year decorates
their house outside with 50,000 light
bulbs to help raise funds and raise
awareness for sick kids which is a
hospital yes for Sick Kids Hospital the
threes are wearing it for Sick Kids
Hospital and this family doesn't live
that far from where we are so i thought
we're gonna go check it out it's about
some holiday cheer we haven't seen it
ever before so we're gonna check it out
for ourselves and sharing the journey
with you guys so here we go everyone
what you got a Pikachu hey you got it
hayden got a source Pikachu hooked him
up go he's pretty excited mm-hmm it's
pretty excited good job vested they
could see there is no okay let's go find
the house
[Music]
this is crazy it smells like fire
something all right did you guys see
that look look at that to the house
that's crazy huh what do you think you
honey this is a house
pretty crazy huh
they do this to raise money for Sick
Kids you can put donations in the in the
box they're raising money for the local
hospital
so I think these are them the did the
rosario family pretty cool look at the
garage filled lights they have to put up
this is what the house looks like
normally okay let's go
you
[Music]
what do you think mr. 50,000 like pretty
crazy huh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that was pretty crazy pretty fun that's
a lot of dedication that that family has
to raise money for charity you guys have
a Christmas message Nina Christmas a
message no Christmas Merry Christmas
Antoninus kisses varsity people okay
there you go hating what's your
Christmas message that's it what else
you want to say thank you merry
christmas and i will say Merry Christmas
and believe yeah however you want where
it is and whatever your one worded have
a great Christmas guys have been an
awesome year super from for 2017 and for
those of you who celebrate other
holidays sending you lots of joy and
blessings and have an amazing 2017 let's
crush it together